it's absolutely horrifying to hear this
the news this morning my condolences go
out to um al jazeera it's reporters
jadin's family and friends and
colleagues um it's it's
the last thing any of us want to hear
when a journalist
is killed doing their job and and i
think
as you just heard from nida
she was trying to tell the story of
what's taking place and i think what's
taking place in janine right now is
exactly why we need journalists like
shireen so badly
there have been
uptick in killings of palestinians of
violence across israel and palestine in
recent weeks that story whenever there
are reports of killing so often isn't
told and shireen woke up in the early
morning to go tell that story and was
killed while doing that and i think it's
absolutely horrific
it's of course not a one-off event
you know we know that israeli forces
systematically have used excessive force
you just mentioned the the gaza march of
return and i think that's a great place
to start the un commission of inquiry
investigated those events and documented
that israeli forces shot
at journalists knowing who they were so
this is an event that needs to be
understood
in the context of the systematic
practice and the killings of many other
palestinian journalists so human rights
watch is still investigating the
specifics of what took place you've
heard the eyewitness testimonies of
other palestinians who have been there
who talked about
being in close proximity to israeli
forces there being no palestinian
resistance in the area but i think it's
important to understand this in the
context of the systematic practice of
excessive force by israeli forces
so now uh investigations
should and will be carried out to a
greater or lesser extent how confident
are you about that process
israeli investigations are a white
whitewash mechanism that is the
assessment that's been reached by human
rights organizations including israel's
premier human rights organization
betsellem human rights watch has a
similar diagnosis israeli forces
regularly when news you know if their
crimes are reported say they'll
investigate those are routinely leading
to a whitewashing mechanism no
accountability these kinds of killings
highlight the necessity of the
international criminal court moving
forward you know with its uh formal
probe into uh serious crimes committed
in palestine because the reality is
there is no
um accountability for these sorts of
abuses when it comes to uh actions by
the israeli authorities
and what more can you tell us about the
record of treatment of palestinian
journalists by israeli security forces
look i mean we we have a long record
that states back decades of palestinian
journalists being detained arrested for
their for their reporting human rights
watch is documented on these incidents
and of course um israeli forces
regularly use excessive force uh and uh
and other means that that go far beyond
what international law authorizes in the
way it polices demonstrations in the
surrounding areas and we've seen
journalists shot at and killed including
you know
for example
in gaza during the gaza march of return
and as noted the un investigated those
events the commission of inquiry formed
to look into these events and made a
clear point of noting that their
conclusion was that israeli forces fired
at those journalists knowing full well
who they are
what measures would you say can be taken
if any to protect journalists better
particularly in this region
look i think it's important that states
uh you know put pressure on the israeli
government the reality here is that this
is happening
against the backdrop of systematic
violence against palestinians the
killing of you know journalists the
arrests of journalists comes place
because there's a lot obviously a larger
practice is taking place against the
context of the israeli government's
crimes against humanity of apartheid and
persecution against palestinians uh
journalists for the for the for
international journalists you know of
course for the most part can enter uh
report across israel palestine uh could
do so with a degree of freedom you know
uh that that's different than other
areas but palestinian journalists face a
very different you know reality um and
and those like shireen that were on the
absolute front lines bravely reporting
at the early hours of the morning i mean
those are exactly the kinds of
journalists that uh you know are most at
risk so i think states need to
understand this against the larger
practice a lot of the statements we're
seeing pouring out in recent minutes uh
you know are calling for an
investigation knowing full well that
won't take place
at the hands of an israeli
whitewash mechanism what's necessary of
course now is not only accountability so
support for mechanisms like
you know the international criminal
court for the un commission of inquiry
but also steps taken uh by uh states to
end all forms of complicity
in the serious crimes committed by
israeli authorities
okay we'll leave it there for the moment
to appreciate your perspective on this
uh shakira israel and palestine director
for human rights watch thanks for
talking to us here